From the Library of Congress and the Smithsonian National Museum of African American History and Culture.
Okay, good morning. Today is Sunday, December 13th, 2015. This is David Klein from Virginia Tech, and working with the Southern oral history program at UNC Chapel Hill, also with the Library of Congress and the Smithsonian's National Museum of African American History and Culture.
Today we have the honor of being with Mr. Dion Diamond, who I will ask to introduce himself in just a moment. We have the camera today.
We have John Bishop from Media Generation. We also have with us today Gouha Shankar from the Library of Congress.
So Mr. Diamond, I just would like to say good morning, and thank you very much for being part of this project, and if you could just introduce yourself, but I appreciate it.
Good morning. I'm Dion Diamond, and I thank you for having me as a part of the project. I look forward to seeing you outcome.
Wonderful. Thank you. So I'd like to start just by we're obviously going to talk about your involvement in the Civil Rights Movement, but I want to start with your childhood, and if you could just tell us a little bit about where and when you are raised, and I'll ask you a few questions about your family, the kind of influences that you may have seen as you got.
More involved in in the movement itself.
Okay, let's try this one. I'm originally from Petersburg, Virginia. The first 18 years spent in Petersburg, a totally segregated community, segregated high school, and our interest school, and even the state college there was essentially all black.
At least I don't even know now whether or not it was black, Negro or Colott, we've come through so many iterations.
At any rate.
Petersburg, as I said, was truly a segregated town. And as I grew up, I don't know how I really got involved, but I was involved in sit-ins before sit-ins became a named item.
I would go into the local five-in-dime store and see the Colott water fountain and the white water fountain.
I would see the lunch counter that I wasn't allowed to sit at, which I did.
And of course, when the waitress of the counterperson spoke to me and said, you know, we can't serve you, I would continue to sit.
And then she would call the manager. The manager would come over and I would still sit.
And then she would call the police. That's what I left. So my sit-ins were very haphazard, spontaneous, and the local library.
There was a color entrance at the rear. And we were allowed to go into the stacks. And of course, I would go into the color entrance, but I would venture into the stacks.
And at any rate, I just thought it kind of crazy that I should grow up in an environment like that.
I don't know where that influence came from because there was no integrated activity that I could look at in Petersburg and know it.
There was anything about it. I think when I was 16, I went to a town called Monticello, New York to work supposedly in a laundry.
And the cat skills and that's what they formally call the Jewish apps. And all of these big hotels would send their laundry to a laundry-cleaning facility.
And I went at 816, well, soon to turn 17, but supposedly to work at the laundry.
There were many kids from my town went there and that's how I found out about it.
And they had no work available at the laundry. I'm walking down the street and here's this restaurant. The name of it was the Frontier.
They were putting the finishing touches on it. It had an open and it said, help warn it.
I walked in and said, hey, look, I've had experience as a short-order cook. And if you need, you know, a short-order cook, I'd like for you to consider me.
And you have references. And of course, I said, yes, I'm lying to my teeth because I had no previous experience out of the cooking-my-famous kitchen.
I ran to the nearest payfold, called Why Aren't in New Brunswick, New Jersey. Her name was Janet Morgan.
I said, hey, if someone calls you and asks, you know, if I cooked in your restaurant and you own Morgan's restaurant now, so I fabricated my experience.
Anyway, I got the job. I think it was about a month later, the guy said, you know, I figured out soon after you started working that you didn't know a dog thing about being a short-order cook, but you picked it up so quickly, that was it.
But that experience in Monticello was my first exposure to persons who were white.
Because again, Petersburg totally segregated. Monticello, rather an integrated community, both religiously and color-wise.
I started Howard University in September of 1959.
I was a physics major.
Shortly after that, when Snick was founded in the city and started in Greensboro, we at Howard supposedly, the pit of me, the capstone in Black education, were doing nothing because DC proper was not legally, or by law, segregated, even though in fact, you know, it certainly was.
Let me interrupt you just for a second. So you said you have this kind of got reaction against the segregation that you had grown up with in your town.
Did you ever talk about it with your peers or with your family? And then when you got to Howard, was that something that, you know, even though nothing was happening immediately there, was that something that was discussed?
No, it was not discussed until the city and started in Greensboro. And that's when we started talking about it because what are we doing about it?
And as you can imagine back then, if you crossed Potomac River into Virginia, you've got segregation.
If you crossed the imaginary line, or the district line into Maryland, western avenue, or eastern avenue, you've got segregation.
And we said, we've got to do something here in DC at Howard. So we organized this group called the Nonviolent Action Group.
And we went over to Virginia to the segregated drug fair, drug chain, lunch counter, and had our first city, and this is after, of course, North Carolina.
So do you remember first reading about the Greensboro, very first?
Yes.
And I said, well, again, nothing in DC we can do, even though believe it or not.
Back then, they didn't even want, you could go into the most expensive min shop, and they didn't want you to try on the clothing.
So that was a kind of a bitter thing, you could have had the money to purchase, but they did not want you to, I guess, so all their clothing.
But again, off first city was at the, the cherry deal, I'm going to say the drug fair in cherry deal over in Alexandria.
We desegregated that entire area within two weeks. And I don't know if you've seen it, but there's this picture.
In fact, it's in the closet.
George Lincoln Rockwell of the American Nazi party came in and surrounded us as we had to sit in. And it was just amazing.
I'm surprised that I didn't panic. It's amazing when you're young and reckless.
I call it the eupholic zuberance because I must admit we were in some dangerous situations.
And it never occurred that day. It says dangerous as it is. Oh, why is it?
So I've seen the pictures. Your calmness emanates out of these pictures. And I needed to ask you about that.
As I look at that picture today, I'm surprised.
You know, I may be getting ahead of myself, but there's this big debate that there was this big debate and probably still is as to whether or not violence is a philosophy or whether or not it's a tactic or whether or not it's an expansion of religion.
I'll let you know well into this one. I believe nonviolence as a tactic.
I don't believe it in it as a philosophy.
My reasoning is the police and the army have the guns and the ammunition that we had nothing.
So we're good with it to be somewhat violent. But off camera and off the sit-ins, hey, if you're back me, I'm going to try to lose my shoe up your head.
So I truly believe in it as a tactic and several of the people whom I get presentations with indeed believe it as a way of life.
And I whenever that there are three of us who usually combine to give these presentations and almost immediately one of us will say, well, I like my two fellow freedom writers.
I believe it as every way of life and then someone else would say, well, one is a minister. He believes it as a philosophy and a religious path.
But at any rate, after that desegregation within two weeks in Virginia, we said, well, what else can we do?
There was this amusement park right across the Maryland line called Glennaco.
And they used to bus white kids from the city to this amusement park. But people of color could not utilize the facilities.
Well, it wasn't as if we could have a sit-in inside the park because we couldn't get in.
So we put up a picket line around the outside of the park. And I think for that entire summer, for the balance of that summer, we just picket it.
The people who live in...
This is the summer of 1960?
Yes.
That's it. The summer of 1960.
I think the most outstanding memory I have of that is the people in Glennaco, which is mostly a Jewish community, which had covenants that you could not sell your house to...
Well, you know what I'm saying.
What I found the most interesting aspect of that was I put on...
I don't know if you'd call it a Gashiki, but a traditional gown worn by persons from Africa.
And including whatever the headband is called.
One of the... How about the name of Hyman Bookbag, if I recall correctly, who was a high up in the labor movement, arranged for this big long black limousine and a white uniformed chauffeur and a white female interpreter?
I'm sitting at the back of the limousine, wearing this African gobb with my interpreter.
We pull up in front of Glennaco.
The show gets out, opens the door.
I step out.
And in my pigeon...
Fitch.
I'm trying to walk into the park and I said,
J2Z, open the park, meet no!
And I thought I was saying I wish to enter the park right now.
And I hope that's how it came out.
But anyway, this security guard who had to be at least 65 years of age and frail.
I mean, he...
I mean, they were charged if it was him.
But that entire summer we picketed Glennaco.
And the following year when schools started again, the freedom rights started.
Well, they started, I think, in March.
When it almost ended after the burning of the bus in Aniston, Alabama,
several of us said, oh, I said, wait a minute.
It's time we don't let this die.
So we venture to Montgomery, Alabama to continue the ride from Montgomery to Jackson, Mississippi.
And I don't know if you have seen the changing of the guard in Buckingham, Palace.
But as they shifted from Alabama to Mississippi,
at least for 50 yards on either side of the highway,
National Guardsmen, two state police cars in front, two behind in a helicopter flying overhead.
We get to the state line,
the bus stops on the opposite side on the Mississippi side.
Two state police cars in front, two fell in behind,
and the helicopter, this time, obviously, the Mississippi National Guard or the Mississippi State Police,
are shoving us into Jackson, Mississippi.
I can only say that we didn't have time and didn't know at the time that a deal had been made
between the governor of Mississippi and Bobby Kennedy.
This was when we were having a big problem with crew chef and the missile crisis and all the rest of it.
You can't very well have the president of your country going talking about the duplicity,
if you will, of the people of Russia and yet here in America, you got the same problem.
So the deal was cut that they would not allow us to be beaten,
but we would be arrested immediately.
And true enough, as soon as we stepped off the bus in Jackson,
we were told to move on.
And if we started for the white waiting room, you were under arrest.
That's why this book, if I may, reached a piece.
That was what the charge was.
We were reaching the piece of Mississippi.
Now, what did you think your relationship was at that point or what was your relationship with the president and with the attorney general?
You had no idea that this was going on in a closed door.
Our salvation at the time was the cameraman, the newspaper reporters.
We just thought that as long as they covered us, you know, the word would get out.
And the pictures would get out just like the pictures of Rockwell over at Owington, Alexandria.
You mentioned that before.
I was going to follow up on that that, you know, you could get up in someone's face,
maybe when the cameras weren't rolling, when the camera was rolling,
you're going to present something.
So this was very conscious.
You were courting the media and thinking about how this would play.
Do you remember this conversation, sort of, again, that's another tactic.
Do you remember those conversations planning this?
No.
I had no, many people who went on the freedom route or engaged in sit-ins had, quote, non-violent training.
My training was strictly on the job.
And from my previous experience in Petersburg again, and then over to Virginia and England, I call.
But I just knew that there was a no-win situation for me to, you know, try to start a fight.
The people surrounding us outnumbered us.
And back then, hey, I'm still way up 128 pounds.
There's one picture that I don't know the date, but Jack Magazine had a photographer
by the name of Larry Still.
And we were in Nashville picking a grocery chain.
And I don't even recall the incident.
But the picture that appeared in the magazine was a non-violent punch.
And it shows me of what purports to be me.
Give it somebody a right cross.
I don't know how I could forget that.
And I'm just wondering whether or not that picture was really not of me, but just someone looking someone like me.
But no, there were no discussions.
We had a, I think, I don't know how long it lasted, but there was a guy who got a grant
to have a month-long seminar for quote, suffolite leaders.
And I was fortunate enough to be selected to attend it.
And we talked about stuff like philosophy, tactic, et cetera.
And even then, you know, I was very vocal in terms of what I believed it to be as I've explained it somewhat already with you.
I just can't imagine myself going through life turning the other cheek, if you will.
So that's how that went in.
And yet there were those moments where you were able to do that, even though it must have been very, very difficult.
Oh, yeah, it was difficult.
Again, I just knew that I represented more than me.
And if the picture got in the newspaper or on television, my hitting someone,
whatever sympathies we might have had a good will, would be down the tube, and literally down the tube.
So no, I mean, I was very aware of it.
I'm not certain how much we actually coded the press, but I knew Don Well that there were times that I gave performances for the benefit of the press.
And I restrained myself for the benefit of the cameras.
So back to the freedom ride.
Let's pick up where you were telling that story that we rest.
Well, first of all, when we went, I was on the bus that arrived in Jackson on the very first day of the continuation of the ride.
What I found interesting is that one bus pulled in, I think we were there an hour later.
I don't recall now how many of us on that bus.
But there were National Guardsmen with Bannets, you know, on Sheeves on the bus with us.
So we used to think, or I used to think, naively, that, wow, we're being protected.
What I didn't realize was, hey, these National Guardsmen until they were put on active duty with the same guys who were coming from out of their neighborhoods, cheering us and giving us holy hell.
I just, it didn't register at any rate.
When we arrived in Jackson and we were immediately arrested, we were thrown into the Hines County jail.
It was almost like a drunk tank.
We were all there collectively.
And we didn't know that there were any other persons who would follow us.
We just thought we were it.
Then we were moved from the County jail a couple of days later to the County prison farm and from the prison farm to the state pinnit entry.
And all the while, not knowing that the buses were continuing to come into town and coming to town.
And what I was trying to explain previously, when people find out you were a freedom rider, they ask you, did you know so and so?
Who was also a freedom rider.
And once we were arrested, let me tell you, white males were segregated from the black males, white females were segregated.
So you didn't know everyone who was a freedom rider.
You mainly knew the persons who were on the same bus that you were on or who got arrested at the same time.
But it was weeks before we found out that the reason we were being moved was because they ran out of space.
And it was interesting when they took us to the state pin.
I was in the same, they put us at, it was called, I think, death row.
But there were two people to a cell.
You couldn't see who was in the cell next to you, but you only, you could talk.
I shared a cell with Jim Fomer, who was then the director of CORE.
And, you know, twice in life, well, perhaps more than twice, but twice in the civil rights movement.
I have, I became somewhat humbled to be in a cell with Jim Fomer, and my supposedly being a leader at the local level and being as vociferous as I was.
You know, there were times when I would ask Jim Fomer a question and I get a monosyllabolic response.
And it was just quiet.
And, you know, I was just humbled to be in the same cell.
The second person that I actually occurred with was Bob Moses.
Bob and I shared a house in McCone, Mississippi for some time.
And the same thing was true.
I couldn't stand being in the same movement and just being quiet.
You know, I tried to strike a conversation.
And, again, this mono response.
But those were two people that I just felt humbled by.
Yeah, it's, and the other thing about it is once again, talking about Petersburg, Virginia.
Didn't realize it at the time, but Bob Moses had relatives in Petersburg that didn't know it until later we started talking.
He's got cousins, he's got relatives, relatives, relatives.
And it's just amazing how the intertwining, if you will, of people from disparate parts of the country ended up either in a cell or a picket line together.
Who else did you know in the movement who had grown up in Petersburg?
And I was just wondering why I walked in to I think Cotton the whole gamut.
And they had no influence whatsoever for my involvement because it happened post Petersburg.
Because I never got arrested with those individual sittings that I had in Petersburg.
And no one knew about it except for the people behind the counter.
And there wasn't something that I went home and buried about.
That's the other thing.
Sometimes people ask me, well, what did your parents think about your involvement?
Or, many of the kids because they were under age had to have parental consent.
Well, I have, like my leaving home at age 17, to go to New York to work.
Who ever heard of a kid at that age going to work in a distant location for the summer?
Anyway, I've always been rather independent.
I've always been somewhat of a leader.
President of my high school, senior class, president, member of the student council,
president of the freshman class at Harvard, you know, the whole gamut.
I've been somewhat independent.
And I never had to ask for permission to do rid of the things that I did.
When people asked what did your parents think, they didn't even know about it until it appeared.
He didn't the newspaper or television or some reporter calling.
And the same thing was true for several of the other artists.
There's a minister from Virginia Union, not sure are, but his name is Reginald Green.
And he's right here in DC also.
And he said, my parents, his parents didn't know about it until a reporter knocked on the door.
And informed them.
And I guess to put it mildly, my parents were very proud of my involvement,
but they just wished it was someone else's child.
I don't know.
They wouldn't worry, right?
I guess we can...
Tell me about it.
I've got a lot to cover, but we left you in prison.
The first of many, I'm sure, from the Freedom Ride.
Did you eventually...
Yeah, I can't play out that.
I can say I go ahead and do that right.
After losing that semester out of school, I thought I was going for a long weekend.
The last two years have changed.
When I got out of Punchman, I flew to Atlanta and said, well, let's see.
The semester's gone.
What can I do now that I'm already down here?
And they had this project in Mississippi, based in Pike County, where I admit,
the whole area around McComb, and that was my first assignment.
So you had known some of the SNCC folks, but you had not formally been involved
when you, at the time, that you were doing the Freedom Ride, or were you already?
Well, because of my involvement in D.C., that made a connection.
So, yes, I knew a few of you.
Also, from that summer seminar retreat in Nashville, that's where I met most of the Nashville people.
And there were quite a few, but there were other some other parts of the country.
And I still don't know how that came about, because it was really a change moment.
To meet the people who ended up in the newspaper, Diane Nash, Jim Bevel, Bernard Lafayette,
I met all of them before the Freedom Ride at any rate.
It's amazing that the relationships that were formed have been lasting.
I mean, here we are 50 some years later, and every time we see one another,
the Smithsonian has brought us together more than one occasion.
This is my first trip with the Library of Congress, but when we've had these gatherings,
and especially the 50th anniversary, it's just amazing how we automatically just coalesced once again.
And the other thing that was amazing, when we were arrested for the Freedom Ride,
there was not one African-American or the police force.
There was not one African-American elected to public office.
So when I went back to McComb to do voter registration activity,
the thought was perhaps one day we might get a commissioner,
or we might get an elected official, never in our wildest dreams did we realize what we had unleashed.
Never thought about the person of color being in the US Congress or the US Senate.
When we went back for the 53th Union, the mayor of Jackson, African-American,
the warden at the State Penitentiary, African-American female, and police force,
you know, I recognize now what happened. The town became gentrified.
Not the other way around, I suppose I should say, the whites moved to the suburbs,
and the blacks became the majority. So that's how that transformation came about.
But we did not realize that we'd have African-American congresspersons,
and most certainly hadn't given it a thought to an African-American president.
Times have changed, but still there's a lot more to be done.
And I don't know if it's on the Library of Congress or...
But somewhere downtown on one of the buildings, there's this Shakespearean phrase,
what is past is prologue. I think that's true.
If you don't know your history, you should. You can very easily revert to what existed previously.
And every time I give a presentation these days, I make it a point.
Most people under the age of 35 today have no idea as to what the Civil Rights Movement was about,
what the freedom rise were about, and that's sad, because if the kids don't know,
we could very easily revert to what existed previously.
And I try to make it a point. Education is indeed the most prominent way of clearing this up,
maintaining what we accomplished.
19 and 1st got involved in this. Did you have a sense of what was at stake?
Did it feel like a choice to you, or did it feel like something that you had to do?
I think it's a ladder.
I had no idea where it was going.
I just knew that I wanted to make my contribution to make a difference.
That might sound somewhat nebulous, because I'm not certain that I could have defined then what I was contributing to.
I just knew I wanted to break down the barriers of segregation.
I didn't have any long-range plans. I had no idea really what the outcome was going to be.
Of course, if we were successful as we had been at Leneco, I'm sorry, at the lunch counter over in Virginia,
I had an idea that we could make a difference. We could bring about change.
You just bring back to McComb and take you back to that time.
You went to Atlanta and got assigned to Mississippi.
What was Mississippi like in 1961?
You were telling us about the change, but can you paint us a picture of what?
Oh, in 1961.
You didn't get the chance to say, oh, you mean after I got out of jail?
I'm most certainly didn't see Mississippi, but Mississippi right now is a jail.
I don't know how to describe it, other than the fact that it was worse than Petersburg.
But it was also more fearful. I was more fearful.
I was aware of the danger as opposed to Petersburg.
The only thing that could have happened in Petersburg was white cop could have picked me up and taken me home.
And said, hey, you're side of the town, so I'm raising you all.
And which would have been true.
But I mean, Mississippi, I was fearful.
The other thing that's interesting is the house that I was in with Bob Moses,
the lady's name was, and that's name was cotton.
We used to call it Mama Cotton.
She was independent, had a house.
And I don't know if you can gather this one, but the house had a two car garage.
But where the doors for the two car garage might have been,
which transformed into a latisse window.
Do you know what I mean by?
Just windowpains above, say, bed, bed level.
My bed in this lady's house was parallel to this latisse window.
At night, we just pulled the curtains and, like most southern towns,
persons of color lived near the railroad tracks.
And almost every night around 11 o'clock, you could hear this free train going up a grade.
And this one particular night, once again, remember, I had something like a 24-inch waist,
not like the present state of pregnancy that I'm now to see, look like.
But a shotgun blast came straight through the window, passed over my body.
Literally, if I would have had this girth then, a part of my body would have been shot off.
But that really made me realize, yeah, the danger that we're in now.
Unlike the stuff that happened after 61-62, Freedom Summer,
Bob Moses and Company up in the Delta, I got pulled out of, well,
I got sent to Holly Springs, Mississippi, from McCone,
and to do the very same thing, voter registration.
Well, just after I'd gotten there, there was a guy by the name of E. Shelton Clock,
who was the president of Southern University.
Now, the kids in Baton Rouge had started having sit-ins.
While I was at Holly Springs, the president closed the school
and kicked out a bunch of, quote, leaders.
Well, Holly Springs is just a short jump from Baton Rouge.
So I went over to Baton Rouge to get some of the kids who, school is closed,
this is almost like over the Christmas holiday period.
To come back to Holly Springs to work with the unvoteer registration.
But as soon as I get there, I've already called the bus company
to try to have a couple of buses to bring them to Holly Springs.
Now, the fallacy that occurred,
while I was getting the kids organized to come to Holly Springs
and to go to Holly Springs, I hadn't arranged for any type of living quarters for them.
But anyway, while I'm in Baton Rouge, the guy reopens the school
and everything that I was over there trying to do is down, down the tubes.
When he reopened the school, he suspended.
Several of the students who were supposed leaders.
So since everything had been wrecked,
I started organizing as a student on Baton Rouge's campus to boycott classes
until the president reinstated a lot of the quote, leaders.
I think I was there for about four days,
going in and out of classroom buildings,
opening doors, telling people, come on, boycott, boycott.
And with a very short two days, whatever.
I somehow ended up in somewhat of a leadership role on a foreign campus.
I mean, the people in Baton Rouge had never even heard of me prior to this activity.
Well, I guess they figured they'd had enough of this.
And they sent the state police, plus the campus police, to get me.
And they got me.
I was charged with trespassing, vacancy, disorderly conduct.
The main charge, those all misdemeanors.
The main charge they got me on was criminal anarchy.
They said I was attempting to overthrow the state of Louisiana.
And in fact, that's true.
I mean, I was.
If you get enough people to vote, you can change the constitution and all the rest of the stuff.
But then you rate them.
Here's something that I didn't realize until Baton Rouge.
Every time that I'd been arrested previously, it had been with a group of people.
And there's safety in numbers.
But when I got arrested in Baton Rouge, they flew me in a cell with the general population.
And here's why that one stands out so much because one, I didn't know a soul.
And at the East Baton Rouge Parish jail, if you're convicted of anything that's a misdemeanor,
you're thrown in the same cell block as someone who's already been convicted of murder,
but waiting for transportation to Angola or the state-pitted entry.
And while in there, I saw a couple of kids who stole a car when you were riding on a weekend.
And by the time Monday morning came around, they had been reaped.
And once again, I was a frail, skinny kid.
And my voice was at least an octave higher than it is there.
What was interesting about that was,
somehow the word got in that population that I was a freedom rider.
Now, the term freedom rider became synonymous with civil rights worker.
And when they found out what I was in there for, I gained a certain amount of respect.
And the thing that was also interesting is that the white guards at toll once again,
it's all black male population.
Had told them, hey, if you give them a rough time, we'll see if we can get you a time off a good behavior.
So that's where I became really concerned.
I mean, if you convicted a murder, you were in your way to the state-pitted for a long time.
You got nothing to lose.
At any rate, when I did get a chance to talk to the local lawyer who represented the NAACP,
somehow he was able to contact the FBI and they moved me to solitary confinement.
Now, one thing I'm pleased with about myself, and I didn't find out until this particular time,
I can deal with solitary and my own solitary too very easily.
But if you can imagine, I guess that cell was about eight feet by,
well, a square eight feet by six feet probably, at any rate.
They would leave the lights on for 24 hours a day, but turned the lights out.
The only way I could tell the time of day, there's still going the middle of one with it,
but the stuff you see on TV, they would bring, I knew it was Saturday,
I knew Saturdays when they give you tours, give the general public tours of the jail.
See that, Tommy? Girl Scouts, boy Scouts, just parading through and showing me off at any rate.
The only way I could tell the time of day was breakfast was somewhere around 5'3''.
Lunch was around 11'10' and 11'30' and dinner was around 4'''.
That's how I could tell the time of day, but other than that,
I had my imagination to keep me going.
And, you know, I survived.
I think when I got out of there, I've been in voter registration activities in Maryland,
I don't know if the name Gloria Richardson has come up in your travels,
but I'm now blocking for some reason this little town on the eastern shore of Maryland
and once again the local folks put me up in their homes and treated me most kindly
and we went about voter registration.
It's been an interesting life.
It most certainly has.
You know, when you apply for a job, it used to be if you applied for a federal job,
and now it's almost if you apply for any job, they ask you have you ever been arrested.
And with Tony and Cheek, I've been arrested approximately 30 times,
connection with civil rights activities. Please check with the FBI for dates and location.
Because I most certainly don't remember all of them.
But, you know, I think to to to to culminate this,
we were, excuse me, we were preparing for this is the years now, now 1963.
We were trying to raise funds for sneak activity, voter registration activities.
And I was sent to Columbus, Ohio to go to the annual Congress of the National Student Association,
which I said annuals for years, it's once a year, and we thought that we could get college campuses in the north
to get kids to volunteer for the following freedom summer and voter registration activities.
I was standing next to a guy who was reading a newspaper, I was just looking over his shoulder,
I was seeing my college class was the class of 63.
Kids were graduating and getting decent jobs.
And I said, wait a minute, I've been down here for two years and change.
And I don't know why I said it out loud. I think it's time for me to get back in school.
Well, I happened to be standing next to the guy who's a president of the student government at the University of Wisconsin.
He said, would you consider coming to Wisconsin? I said, are you kidding?
Now, if you remember then, Berkeley and Auburn and Madison were the hot spots.
This is August of 63. He says, don't move. He ran across the gymnasium floor that had been set up for the Congress,
came back with what I thought was a fairly elderly man, he must have been in the 30s.
You know, back then, you obviously hit it at 30s, oh, at any rate.
This is late August. The guy asked me, he turned out to be the dean of students.
I understand you might be interested in Wisconsin. I said, yes, he says, how are your grades?
I said, hey minus B plus, can you get a transcript? Yes.
He said, get me a transcript. I went running to the newspaper, called the registrar at Harvard,
had my transcript forward into Wisconsin by the 9th of September when school started, I was enrolled.
Now, you're talking about certain deputy. This was true to you.
I was a physics major at Harvard, but when I got to Wisconsin because of my civil rights activities,
I wanted to know, why did it take 50 years or approximately from the emancipation proc-
I mean, 100 years from the emancipation proc-
for there to be an organized protest. So I changed my major to history and sociology, civil war reconstruction.
I still can't answer that question today.
I guess it really takes a few folks with either stupidity or insight as a case maybe,
to just say, well, maybe if we do this, we can create change.
That was my first serendipitous college transfer.
In 1966, I came to DC to work for the local anti-poverty organization, the United Planet Organization.
Back then, of course, that was when Johnson and all of the money was being poured into anti-poverty,
sod and shriver, and that group. I'd been working here until 1968.
And one of the women that I worked with was working for OEO,
which was the National Office of Economic Opportunity, which funded the local groups.
And I guess for some reason, she was impressed with the way that I worked with her.
And I'm almost certain this had some influence, but she said, D.I.,
would you be interested in going to Harvard? Now, are you talking about what I consider the silly question, of course.
Well, I did a great, I ended up at Harvard.
And once again, still trying to figure out what was the answer to that question,
I got into race relations and sociology. Still can't answer that question, but he is a funny part about Harvard.
I'm almost certain that this was during the period of time when they were trying to diversify, you know, the student population.
I like to think it was also because I had grades, and I was deemed to be competent.
But what surprised me at both Wisconsin and at Harvard, because this did not change,
it was Wisconsin, I think, out of about 18,000 students, they were less than 50 African Americans.
And most of them were either on the basketball team or on the football team, you get my drift. They were athletes.
When I got to Harvard, oh, and the same thing, I'd sit in the class and I'd be the only personal color.
And somehow they became aware of my civil rights activities, and they would look at the teachers, the profs would look at me for verification, as if, you know, I can speak for all persons of color.
I got to Harvard. In several of my classes, you had to provide a resume in order for them to choose 15 students who they thought would make the best class.
In almost every case, I was the only African American in the class. And every time they would defer.
To me to verify something and call upon as you are interviewing me, call upon my civil rights experience and mind being a native silencer, to speak for, to ratify, justify how you were going to put it, you know, what they were teaching.
And I felt uncomfortable in that role. But by the same token, I was the only one in there who could either verify or refute.
So I just assumed that role. The other thing about Harvard, I don't know how this is going to come across. I think the hardest thing about Harvard is to get in.
Once you're in and you're able to show what you know and what you're capable of doing, it's very easy.
And I made one mistake of many I think, but the biggest mistake I made at Harvard was almost the same when I made it Wisconsin.
I didn't form any lifelong friendships.
I still relate to the kids I went to school for three semesters with at Harvard more so than, you know, anyone I went to school with at Harvard.
I meet kids today who say, yeah, I got the Harvard. It was after you, but I heard about you. Yeah, I went to Harvard.
I guess again, this has been a heck of a trip. All in all, I would say, you know, it's been a good ride.
I was just going to say there was a lot to separate you from those other students, not just race obviously, but you had to live.
You know, and these were kids that you would been out there.
A lot of life experience can happen in a few years. Oh, that's true quite.
It was a few years because only two years between Harvard, you know, in Wisconsin.
And only three years between Wisconsin and Harvard.
And I guess I was overwhelmed to be a student at Harvard.
Many of the kids ended up at the business school. And then I bumped into people that I did not know were Harvard grads.
They said, yeah, we didn't go to the same school, but I knew you were on campus. Now that's a big campus.
So I don't know. I mean, there's obviously a great fun. Oh, it was obviously a great fun.
So what degree did you leave with that? My degree is in education.
Harvard has an agreement with MIT. I guess you call it a consortium.
Most of my classes were either in MIT or Harvard. Well, I guess basically those two.
And they were not, I think out of all of that, only one course through our recall as being at the grad school of education.
That was indeed race and ethnic relations. That's what I did my thesis on.
Yeah, it's, it's kind of wacky.
I don't know how many people, I don't know how many people who experienced some of the stuff that I experienced have had the opportunity of these serendipitous, you know, segues, if you will.
I know some kids who stayed at Harvard and graduated ended up going to an Ivy League business school, but they didn't have the civil rights experience that I had.
And again, as I said in Columbus, Ohio, I got kind of peed when I found out my class was graduating in the head credentials that I had.
It's time for me to get back in school.
So I want to ask about what you did in your career after Harvard, but I want to dip back very quickly before we get too far away from it to one particular arrest and time in jail.
And this was when I believe it was in Nashville when you were jailed along with Stoke Lee Carmichael.
If I could ask about you know why I'm asking the story about this, but could I ask you to tell that?
And by way of contrast to some of the first stories that you were telling about the lunch counter and walking quietly outside.
I think I have to disappoint you on that one mainly because the fact that that wasn't in Nashville, if I recall correctly.
I think that was supposedly at the state pit of entry in Mississippi.
I may be wrong, but the reason I think I'm going to have to disappoint you is I have read and reread Stoke Lee's account of all being in that cell together.
And I can be the confirmed or deny that that occurred.
I am capable of what he described. I guess for the record.
I guess you really have to read it to appreciate it. Supposedly Stoke Lee and I were in the cell together. Supposedly this guard was halfway high.
Supposedly he was very odd and he had a shotgun.
And according to Stoke Lee, I verbally engaged him and just just said go ahead shoot.
I just don't remember that. I'm capable of it, especially as a ploy because I knew Darnwell.
And Darnwell, there was no way he was going to kill us in a cell with all of the people in the block up and down.
So I just, if I did, I just mouthed off.
But I would recognize it.
When you let someone, you don't do it in a public view.
If you're going to murder someone, you don't do it when you get a whole bunch of witnesses.
So that's the only way I could explain it.
By that particular time, I've never been considered dumb.
And I'm sorry if this is going to come about as a braggitassio.
I've known since I was either a junior or a senior in high school what my IQ was.
And the only reason I know that is because after we took the test, the teachers started pointing at me that diamond boy.
And I didn't know what I'd done because I'd be dying.
I can remember what I'd escalate when we were, I found out that supposedly my IQ is up there.
But again, I didn't know why they were pointing at me at the time because previously we were to be given a standardized test.
And the standardized, of course, means, of course, the country.
I was frightened. I knew there would be no way for a kid to totally segregate a school to compete with white kids and black kids from all over the country on a standardized test.
And this was to be a geometry exam.
And I couldn't fathom taking this test.
So my geometry class was just before, just before lunch.
Right next to my English class. So I unlocked the window.
You've got to picture this. My class was on the second story.
There was an auto mechanic shop with a roof that was right at the step out of the window on the second level.
I threw a baseball out of the English class window onto the roof of the auto mechanic shop.
We went out and mulled around and picked up the ball, but re-entered.
Or the makes-re-mover with a math class. I stole the standardized exam.
Now, the teacher's lounge is a couple of windows away. And they're just sitting there looking at me.
The math teacher knew what I had done. She gave me a zero on the final exam.
I still passed the course because I had nothing but A's for the semester.
Anyway, it was the worst thing I ever did, mainly because of the fact I aced it without having stole the standardized test.
And that led me to understand that I underrated the teachers and the education I was getting in a segregated environment.
And I think I've said this several times before. I think because in a segregated community, everybody knows one another.
The teachers know your parents, your neighbors knew your parents. You could get a spanking between home and school or school and home.
And it was just a given. I mean, it was understood.
But I've said several times since then that we underrated the education that we got.
Because teachers just took more of an interest in you. And they talked to your parents more frequently.
I don't know how valid that state it is, but I think that's about right.
So let me ask you then.
By the way, I'm not suggesting I'm proud of what I just explained.
No, I appreciate your candor.
Just another thing in life.
But at least we're going to ask this question about the obvious advances of the civil rights movement.
And yet there are some things like desegregation of schools that could perhaps be seen as bittersweet.
I agree with you on that.
I mean, based upon what I just said,
teachers don't take as much interest in the students today as they did in this small segregated community.
It is bittersweet because teachers are underrated.
I don't think with the way technology has advanced, teachers have the time to devote to students as they formally did.
You know, you look at movies that depict school life today.
I mean, it's kind of wild.
I don't know how you learn anything in an environment like that.
Schools are now too big to be personal.
I'm not certain how many teachers today really know anything about the home life of their students.
And that makes a difference.
Are there any other losses, do you think, that came along with the gains and so on?
Yeah.
I think there's been a lack of the cohesiveness in forming friendships.
You may say, well, what's the gotta do with anything?
I don't know if people have the binding friendships they had that they experienced in the segregated system.
That's also related to my talking about the teachers.
Maybe the fallacy of my logic is that I'm comparing small town, USA, with the big city.
All of the civil rights experience from my high school education through my civil rights stuff,
were small town oriented, even in DC, when I got to go to Harvard.
It was relatively isolated.
It wasn't the big city, it was just that small campus.
So you get closer to people.
Again, with the civil rights movement and how the colleges today have really grown in terms of student population.
Unless you're living in a dormitory, you really don't get a chance to interact.
I would say this.
I know at historically black schools, they call it HBCU's colleges and universities.
They have been robbed of their most gifted athletes.
The big ten, all of your big schools have recruited the cream of the crop of athletes.
If you look at any professional football team these days, when they were not on the field and tell you where they went to school,
it's almost always a huge institution.
The caliber of athletes that now go to historical black schools has decreased.
Well, that's the social in educational aspect.
Other than that, hey, we've made inroads, but I think the bit of sweetness again is
that lots of us have forgotten from whence we came and don't recognize some of the barriers that still exist.
They're still, they talk about a glass ceiling for women.
There's a glass ceiling for any person of color.
And I truly believe that.
And then every time I say something like that, I look and see.
The president of American Express, or the CEO of American Express, African American.
The president of the CEO of Hollywood American Cruise Line, African American.
So, you look at that and you say, wait a minute, you've made strides.
Look at the rest of the infrastructure.
You've got one or two persons at the top.
But how does that translate, you know, as you go through the ranks?
I've not done a steady to verify what I'm saying.
I get so confused today when I look at athletes who, athletes entertainers.
I don't understand how this society can put such a premium on those persons as opposed to persons who are educated and persons who,
I feel like I've a better word.
The intelligence here.
Because we pay through the nose for guys who are fluent in no language, but can play football.
And how you find out after the fact that, well, they were making all that money and then they broke.
I don't understand how people who hit the lottery or people who get paid these exorbitant salaries.
Who can go out and buy five automobiles when they can only drive one, who buy two and three or four houses.
The next thing you know, so and so is broke.
Well, I don't know where I was instilled with an appreciation for it.
I don't want to say money, but that probably was what it was about.
I always see it growing older and being broke.
I must admit, thankfully, that hasn't happened.
I don't know why I was instilled with that.
My parents were not well, they were about a long shot.
My dad was a male carrier.
My mom was a housewife until the kids were raised.
I had one older brother, then there's me and I'm the first one to get out of college.
I've got two siblings in the younger than I am.
So we never had, you know.
In those days, a male carrier was equated the same as a school teacher.
You get kids graduating from college and they become a school teacher.
You also had kids graduating from college who were going to be the male carrier.
So they were like almost on the same plane.
I can't say that I've been a Fugel, but I haven't been a spin-through.
I guess as you look around, you can say I'm not exactly poor living here.
Two questions, and maybe they're a little bit related.
One is, if you could just tell us a little bit about your career going forward after you finished your education.
The other question is sort of curious about we've met a number of SNCC people who are here in this area in the district
and I'm wondering about how people ended up here and whether those connections continued that you made during the movement.
I'll deal with the latter.
Marion Barry is the reason so many of us are here.
If you recall, this used to be called Chocolate City.
And Marion, when he was mayor, bought more college graduates and SNCC people who ended up in professional positions in city government.
That's one of the reasons.
As to whether or not the relationships that we forged back then still exist, they exist, but we don't socialize.
It took the death of Julian Barr and the death of Marion for us to really just be together as a group.
And you're right, there are quite a few of us here.
Again, it's almost like you don't have to talk with someone in order to maintain a closeness.
And I think that's true in this case.
In terms of my career,
it was a health of a skeleton.
Upon completing my education, I came back to DC
and took a job as the US Department of Labor, my first job out of grad school.
And they had the same problem that some of the colleges had.
They didn't have any African Americans of high enough rank.
And one of the shows you again, one of the women whom I met at Glen Echo had a father who was high up in the Labor Department.
And she introduced me to him and he introduced me to someone else.
And straight out of school, I ended up with a job that was a GS-14.
And I don't know if you know the government rankings.
That's pretty high.
From there, I think I was at the Labor Department for about two years.
And we went to a nonprofit that dealt with...
I worked with training African Americans from all over the country,
but mostly from the South, an economic development.
And many of those students back then whom we had, we trained at...
I was at Berkeley for an entire summer training.
Some students from North Carolina, Durham, Chapel Hill, etc.
who eventually went back to their hometowns and did economic activities, economic development activities.
After that job for about three years, I started my own consulting firm.
And between that and economic development activities and financial and analytical skills that were developed.
I've been a consultant to HUD, to HHS, what used to be HEW.
And perhaps I can just tell you, at HUD it was again race and ethnic relations.
Dealing with segregated housing and how Black-Rand funds were being expended across the country.
From there, I went to HEW.
And I helped that design as a consultant, designing an instrument for determining fraud and abuse in the Medicaid Medicare program.
And we would design the and test it, this instrument all over the country, to find out how come some doctors and some dentists and some pharmacies
would get away with a whole bunch of theft.
That worked.
Then I, again, with my consultancies, I did training for several of the agencies in the race and ethnic relations.
Descending segregated patterns and how to have a more diverse clientele.
I, again, revered it to a job with the DC government in the Department of Housing and Community Development, writing grant applications to be funded by either HUD, or whenever I could pick up the money.
I have been essentially a semi-retired for almost 15 years.
And I still have a couple of clients.
I'm now 74 years old age.
I still have a couple of clients that I deal with, guarding financial advisories.
And when I say almost 15 years and 2008, when we had this financial collapse, I kind of collapsed.
And I'm a leery now and I'm advising anyone on dealing with the stock market investments.
It's enough for me to try to hang on to what I've acquired.
And my spouse on the other hand, whom you met earlier, I cannot stand the thought of retirement.
She continues to work and work.
And I keep saying, hey, I thought retirement was going to allow us to travel.
Well, we do travel, but not to the extent that I had in mind.
I hope that answers your question.
So do you perceive, because I certainly do, but do you perceive a through line from civil rights movement through your work of focusing on reform efforts of various kinds?
Well, let's put it this way.
I'm certain had I not been in civil rights.
I would not, well, three things.
Number one, I would have gone to Wisconsin, two, I would not have gone to Harvard, three.
I don't think I would have the credentials that allow me to deal with racial issues.
I would have been a physicist. I'm certain.
And this, you know, showed your home, my life has changed dramatically from being, you know, a technician or a scientist to being somewhat of a social scientist.
Yeah, I mean, I don't love physics.
I mean, I know the straight line that you're talking about, I don't know if it's straight, but it's never straight.
Can I ask you, because of something that's personally curious to me interested in historically, is that period in the early 70s, I guess, in terms of black economic development, such that was such a crucial period and you were right right in there.
Again, I don't, it's that line that you're talking about. One thing leads to another and I still feel that not enough emphasis is put on it.
You know, people today, indeed, even me appreciated a job with an income as opposed to try to create income.
And I think that's the next hurdle. You know, most people today, irrespective of the race, you know, they really want a job that's going to pay a decent salary, put in the at 20 or 30 years and retire.
I don't know if I was just reading Barron's magazine this morning.
And well, that's the tech firms, the bonds upsellers. There's an article in the paper regarding how this guy got an $800 million bonus.
Can you imagine that? I mean, for making money at a wall speed brokerage.
The tech guy who's the Facebook, he's giving all of his money to and that's a lot of them.
But by the same token, I don't know if you follow Yahoo and the other tech firms that are now having problems.
The article suggests that it's a cycle. Tech firms get created, we make advances.
And then something else is created. And what the first firm has reached its plateau.
So you got to keep creating wealth. And I don't know if enough people recognize that or don't feel comfortable trying to create, they just want safety and they want what?
I guess security is the word I'm looking for. Now, here's the way this one works.
When I was 19, people asked me how do I get it. What would I do the same thing over again?
If I knew then where I know now, probably not. But again, being age 19, not having a house note to pay.
Not having to put food on the table for anyone other than myself. Yeah, I would do that again.
But with age, normally it comes responsibility. And responsibility can curtail a lot of what you can accomplish and what you end up.
So again, I guess combine your question I eat. Would I would I do it again? And two is there a line that shows a progression in terms of how my life has has become?
Yeah, I is definitely there. But again, with economic development, someone has to keep creating wealth because, well, just does not stay the same.
And as I said, in 2008, I made some bad choices. And I guess some of you can relate to that also.
It's funny because when that occurred, my spouse had to me, well, do you know the way you play with this stuff?
You make it back. And 2008 is what? Seven years ago. Well, guess what? I did make it back. But if it happened again, I don't have that much time left to make it.
So that's why I become more fiscal, fiscally conservative. When people ask me, what are my politics? I say, oh, I'm a fiscal conservative.
So let me just ask you a few sort of more reflective questions as we get towards the end.
Yeah, and I've gotten off the surprise beat. Right?
Yeah, so that's one thing I wanted to ask. And we've gotten added a little bit. But what do you think about where we are now and what sort of remains on the table?
Well, I'll tell you personally, I'm disappointed in myself because I have become somewhat of a recluse.
I do nothing now to advance, you know, civil rights in America today. I do nothing to help kids start businesses.
In fact, I guess I'm just out of it. And I think I still have something to offer. And I don't know why that I've become so satisfied, so complacent, so, well, you get my drift.
But then too, when I look at many of my compatriots and also rights activists, they aren't either. You know, this stuff should be generational. It should keep progressing.
And that's why I think I mentioned to you earlier, whenever I make a presentation, I try to instill some type of vigor in our youth.
Because we are not at the same generation, and I really can't even relate to some of the stuff the kids today relate to.
Everything for my choice of music. I don't even know how to use. I can use that computer, but I can't. I can't even use it on my phone.
I purchased one a couple of weeks ago, and it's right up the other shelf.
So, I don't know. I, again, I'm disappointed in myself in that I do no volunteer work and I should.
But then too, when I say I shit, again, I get back to, I don't know how to provide any assistance to the youth because I can't relate to what they relate to.
Does that answer you question? No, it's very much so. But when you see things like the, like just recently, you know, the Black Lives Matter campaign, you know, how do you respond to that?
It shows obviously that there's still great need. But I'll just show you something.
Yeah, but you know something. Folks responding in some way.
I'm not saying how my compatriots might respond to this response.
I don't think there's anything to be gained by saying Black Lives Matter. Lives Matter. And until we get to a point where we see our relationship to one another, there's no need in just going back and saying, hey, Black, White.
I mean, I think those distinctions should be made. But the point is, I see use the term Black Lives Matter kind of segments the issue.
And I don't particularly relate to that.
I think it follows this. When I see what happened in Charleston, I either.
And I said, well, that kind of really shows where we are in this country. I mean, we still haven't, we still haven't cured the problem, if you will.
And every time I hear Donald Trump, I don't mean to do, I do mean to get into politics.
But here we are talking about putting barriers all over the country and keeping a particular ethnic or religious group from even coming here to visit.
That bothers me quite a bit. But for my father's even more than what I find, I wish I could pull it out.
The people who show up at Trump rallies, it kind of tells us something about where we are in the country. There are a whole bunch of people who don't vote.
There are a whole bunch of people who do vote. But if indeed, it's almost like a clan rally.
It kind of shows that we still have a long way to go.
America is a hell of a lot better than it was in the past. And I must admit, every time I leave this country, whenever I get home, I always say, my God, I'm so glad I was born here.
And that kind of sounds like a person is satisfied. But that's not what I'm trying to convey.
This country has indeed come a long way into my knowledge. It's at the forefront of progress compared to other countries in the rest of the world.
And I think I've traveled rather extensively.
I don't know. I mean, every now and then, when I turn on the C. Wait a U.K.
The one that shows all the British programs. You look at Britain or the United Kingdom.
And it looks as if it's a very integrated society. But recently, some racism is becoming apparent there also.
So I don't know. I give accolades to America, but I say we still have a way to go.
And I don't know. Every time, if you look around the South, you'll see a whole bunch of books on race and effort, relations and civil rights.
And every time one of my comrades calls and say, hey, Dion, I'm trying to verify, so and so on. Do you remember?
And I'll say, yeah, what my biggest regret is, I never kept notes. Because I could have written a book.
But now, every time a book comes out, and this shows you, every time a book comes out, one of the first things I do is look at the back and see my name is in there.
But I think that answers your question about a progress we've made and what I think of America. But it frightens me again.
What has passed is prolong. I mean, if we don't watch out, I mean, I'm proud of imagining not only if Trump could become president, if the things that he is professing or advocating would have come about,
it's just frightening. And again, that's what has passed is prolong. He could make a whole past come back, put up a fence with Mexico and make them pay for it.
You forget Ellis Island, right? What this country was based on, what it was made of.
Okay, once again, I'm that grass. No, I don't think it's a that aggression at all.
So I want to ask one final question, but I wanted to see if the folks behind the camera have any questions they'd like to contribute.
I'm just cheering you on. I feel the same way.
Well, again, I didn't I didn't check with you first.
Right. That's right. He's got some power.
So let me just ask the final question, which is there is there anything that I that you expected me to ask today that I should have asked for that I didn't ask that you'd like to address?
No, I think you've got me talking again. I went a long way from civil rights.
And again, I apologize for all of my verbal pauses, but
what was your most memorable moment back from all those things that you can say that it capsulates my moment to the civil rights firm?
Probably when the civil rights bill of 1964 was passed and
to look at all of the elected officials who are now African-American, too.
You know, one thing I didn't bring out and it was very fleeting in 1966.
I'm sorry, 1968.
I had been offered a job running the anti-poverty program out of the Marshall Islands.
Okay. I had been admitted to Harvard.
And I got a job working on Bobbi Kennedy's campaign.
And I had three options. One, I figured if I were to go out to the Marshall Islands and Micronesia.
Even though they said you can come home once a year and you only 90 miles from Japan or something like that,
I figured that probably ended up marrying some Micronesian woman and I'd never get back to the States.
The other thing was I said, well, if Bobbi Kennedy's elected president, I might end up with the job in the White House.
And I said, if none of this stuff falls out, I still got Harvard in the hole.
Well, you know what happened? I didn't go to Micronesia. Bobbi Kennedy got killed and I ended up at Harvard.
Now, all of these things, I pay the hell of a mosaic.
I don't say that regularly. I'm meaning me that most people have not had the experiences that I've had.
And again, it was civil rights that got me into this way, the way I...
And I have benefited, obviously.
And I think the Civil Rights Act and the election of Obama have to be the highlights.
Because again, who the heck expect...
You expected Jack Kennedy to do something in connection with Civil Rights.
You never expected Lyndon Johnson or Southerner to be the guy to implement it.
I never expected to see the elected officials at the level that has occurred.
I hope that answers your question. I mean, that covers a hell of a period of time.
But nevertheless, all of it had its roots, if you will, and my participation in the movement.
Best I can do.
Thank you so much. That was terrific.
This has been a presentation of the Library of Congress and the Smithsonian National Museum of African American History and Culture.